[MUSIC PLAYING]
ACE NASSRI: Hey folks, I'm Ace.
CHEN YU: I'm Chen.
ACE NASSRI: And
today we're going
to be talking about how did you
intelligent Gmail processing
using Cloud Functions.
So first, a quick background
on what we're doing today
and how our application works.
So you probably know about
the various G Suite web
apps, everything from Gmail, to
Calendar, to Slides, to Docs,
to Sheets, so on and so forth.
But what you may not
know about is the APIs
behind these apps that
effectively provide us scalable
and programmatic access to
the G Suite data underlying
these applications.
Now of course, in terms of
what we can do with these APIs,
especially when we combine
them with Google Cloud,
the sky really is
the limit here.
Just to pick on a couple
use cases in particular,
we could say maybe
we want to categorize
images in our Gmail messages
using the Cloud Vision API.
Maybe we want to export
data we generate in GCP--
say, in a BigQuery job or
something-- to Google Sheets.
Maybe we want to even find
sensitive data using the Data
Loss Prevention API that we have
in our Google Drive accounts.
So today, we're going
to focus particularly
on that first use case.
So when it comes to
Gmail processing, what
we're going to try
and do is say we
want to take all of our
incoming images-- or, excuse me,
incoming messages.
And anything that
has an image on it,
we want to find that
image, extract that image,
classify it using
the Cloud Vision API,
and export those
classifiers to--
excuse me-- to
Google Sheets, right?
So that's what we're
going to do today.
And what we can do with this
extension, the sort of "so
what?" if you will, is that we
can use this to easily search
for images in our inbox.
So in terms of the products
and services that we're
going to use today, obviously
we're going to be using Gmail.
And Gmail has this really cool
feature called the Watch API.
Now what the Watch
API lets you do
is send notifications
to a Cloud Pub/Sub topic
whenever you receive
an incoming email.
So Cloud Pub/Sub provides us
simple, scalable message cues
which we can then use to trigger
Cloud Functions, which will
host our event processing code.
So in turn, Cloud Functions then
contacts Cloud Vision and says,
hey, I have an image.
I want you to tell me
what kinds of categories
apply to this image.
So maybe, let's say, it's
an image of blue sky.
So Cloud Vision is going to
say, OK, well, maybe it's blue,
maybe it has the sky in it,
maybe it has to do with nature.
Then, Cloud Functions is going
to take those categories,
export them to a Google
Sheet using the Sheets API.
So now I'm going to
hand it over to Chen,
who is going to talk about
how we built this application.
CHEN YU: Hi.
So this project is actually
a simple five-step process.
First, you set up Gmail
push notifications
so that every time a new message
arrives at your Gmail inbox,
Gmail will send a push
notification to Cloud Pub/Sub.
Cloud Pub/Sub will then
deliver this push notification
to Cloud Functions.
Another function will
query the Gmail API
and download the full message.
If there is an image
attachment, Cloud Functions
will send the image data to
Cloud Region API for analysis,
and Cloud Functions will
then write an analysis
to a Google Sheet.
Now imagine that I send
myself a picture of blue sky.
Gmail will send a
push notification
upon the arrival
of this message,
and the push notification will
be delivered via Cloud Pub/Sub
to the Cloud Functions.
Since there is an
image attachment,
Cloud Functions will
send the image data
to Cloud Vision
API for analysis.
This is a picture of blue sky.
So as Ace has just mentioned,
Cloud Vision API will probably
return results like blue,
sky, nature, et cetera,
and Cloud Functions will write
a result to a Google Sheet.
Now, we would love to talk
more about Gmail, Cloud Vision
API, et cetera.
But before that, we
really want to mention
that accessing G Suite data
requires explicit approval
from end users.
G Suite APIs, along
other Google APIs,
are protected by the industry
standard Open L2 workflow.
Normally, you have to perform
this workflow manually
to get access, but here, we used
this really convenient Node.js
lab array built by the team to
help us automate the process.
Here's the code for handling
the Open Auth workflow.
As you can see, this
package how provides us two
really convenient functions.
Also need and else callback.
The [INAUDIBLE] need
function, as its name implies,
helps initiate the
Open Auth workflow.
And the callback
function processes
authorization data returned
from Google servers,
and save it in persistent
storage for future reference.
Here's a code for downloading
the Gmail message.
As you can see, the code
is pretty straightforward.
You just [INAUDIBLE]
the Gmail API
for the most recent messages.
Gmail API will return you
a number of message IDs,
and you can use those IDs to
download the full message.
Here's a code for analyzing
data using Cloud Vision API.
You basically just send the
image data to Cloud Vision API
and Cloud Vision API will
return you a number of labels,
the categories of the image.
We here detect the
top three labels
and write them to
a Google Sheet.
The code, once again, is
pretty straightforward.
It would simply just call
the Google Sheet API,
tell the API that I
have a new row of data
I need to append to the sheet,
and the Google Sheet API
will perform the operation
automatically for you
behind the scenes.
Now I will hand it back to
Ace to talk about running
and deploy this [INAUDIBLE].
ACE NASSRI: So
you'd think, given
how many different
possibilities are exposed
by this combination
of Cloud and G Suite,
that deploying this would
actually be a lot of effort,
right?
Surprisingly, it's not.
You can generally break it down
into these three simple steps.
So first of all,
you're going to want
to enable these various APIs
that we have listed to the left
here.
Then you're going to want to
download the code by cloning
the GitHub project.
Now, the URL for this is
github.com/googlecodelabs/gcf
gmail codelab.
And unfortunately we are having
a couple of technical issues
with our code labs, but if
and when those are resolved,
you can also check this out
in the hands-on lab section
as well.
Now, last but not
least, you're going
to want to follow the
instructions in that code
lab, which will talk you through
deploying this code to GCP.
And now I'm going
to hand it back
to Chen, who's going to
take us through a demo.
CHEN YU: So we start
this demo by calling
the all see need function.
This function will help
us set up the Gmail push
notifications.
And this function
will redirect us
to the sign-in, this Google
page where you can sign in
with your own Google account.
Here you will see this "this
app isn't verified" warning.
That's because we are
testing this locally.
So it's actually safe
to ignore this warning.
And now Google will tell
us that this app requires
the following
permissions to continue.
Basically, it needs
access to your Gmail inbox
so that it can set up the
Gmail push notification.
You grant the system
the access, you
will see this success
message, "successfully set up
Gmail push notifications."
Now Ace will send me an
email with a picture.
ACE NASSRI: Unfortunately,
we're having
issues with the internet here.
But we have preferred
some of these images
so you can see what it looks
like in the real world.
CHEN YU: Yeah, so basically
as you can see here,
here's a picture
of a beautiful cat.
And this image has been
categorized by the Cold Vision
API here, along with
the sender of the email
and the name of the attachment.
Let's see if the--
it will probably still take a
few seconds for the new message
to arrive.
ACE NASSRI: It's
being quite slow.
So unfortunately our
conference Wi-Fi-- hit or miss.
CHEN YU: Let me give
it one more second.
ACE NASSRI: It's having issues.
We should probably just go on.
Technical
difficulties, everyone.
CHEN YU: Sorry about that.
ACE NASSRI: So
that's it from us.
If you have any questions,
please do let us know.
Either email us.
I am faast@google.com--
faast with two A's.
You can also DM on
Twitter @serverl0ss.
CHEN YU: I'm
chenyumic@google.com.
ACE NASSRI: Thanks
for your time,
and we hope you enjoy
the rest of your time
here at Google Cloud Next.
CHEN YU: Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]